hey what is up guys I'm cabby HD here
and this is the 2014 Moto X or the new
Moto X if you remember the last Moto X
this guy it was a pretty popular phone
for a lot of people who were into tech
because it made us realize that not
everything is about specs and you can
make a really great phone that doesn't
have the highest end specs so this
didn't have a 1080p display it didn't
have the most expensive fastest
processor in the world but it delivered
a pretty sweet experience that a lot of
people liked and that's what it was
famous for this new Moto X is again
taking a very similar approach it's not
the highest end phone in the world it's
definitely not the most expensive but it
does a lot of things about the
experience right at least Motorola's
opinion and they've made some subtle
changes to the software and hardware
experiences with this second revision so
let's take a look at if it's worth it
and if it's better than the old moto x
now aesthetically just looking at the
outside of the hardware this new phone
will seem pretty familiar it has the
same shape same lines same curves and
same feel on the hand as last year's
Moto X even has that same dimple
although this time it's bigger and it's
made of separate pieces that fit
together and for some reason the pieces
in mind didn't quite fit together
perfectly so the dimple moves around a
bit I don't know if that's supposed to
happen
but anyway it's clear that we are
working with essentially the same design
here the button placement on the side is
also the same as the old phone with a
bit of added texture on the power button
which is neat and it feels basically
like a stretched-out Moto X and it also
looks that way but then there's the
addition of all the metal so all the way
around the phone you now have this metal
lining and it makes a huge difference
for build quality and the way it feels
holding it it's a bit heavier as well
but that's a small price to pay for the
fact that it feels so much better so
much more solid in the hand and I love
that the metal frame is now also housing
some new antenna that were in the inside
of the phone before and overall its
built just a lot better than its
predecessor of course you can also have
moto maker and a bunch of different
color and material choices and accent
colors from regular soft touch plastic
to wood to leather now one thing I want
to recommend is I think we would want to
stay away from the leather back one
unless you really have to have it be
coming this is the black plastic back so
it's not the leather
the leather it's a softer material
basically all of the leather moto X's
that I saw when I was playing with them
in Chicago were very worn and I don't
know how long they were using them but
none of them looked like they were in
any good type of condition well there is
a softer material that wears much more
easily and plus it's not exactly
friendly when it gets exposed to water
so if such plastic on the back actually
almost feels the same as the leather
until you start to press down on it and
it doesn't have that genuine leather
smell and it might not feel quite as
premium but I think we'd be pretty
satisfied with pretty much any of the
plastic backs now on the front of the
phone the Moto X has some interesting
hardware it's rocking a 5.2 inch 1080p
display it's an AMOLED display and much
larger than the 4.7 inch of the old Moto
X and it's a tiny bit warm and a whole
lot saturated I've used I guess so many
IPS displays lately that coming back to
this AMOLED display just reminds me how
well oh le D stuff pops with massive
contrast and awesome saturation so the
colors are really vivid here pops right
off the screen and you can tend to make
images look better than they really are
on this screen so I like the display and
flanking the panel on the top and the
bottom
our front-facing speakers well speaker
it's a bit deceiving you have a grill on
the top and a grill on the bottom but
the top is only the earpiece or calls
and the bottom is the only speaker so it
means that you won't get that stereo
effective sounds moving across the
screen like you would on a stereo phone
like the HTC One I mean there's still
better than if it was a downward facing
or rear-facing speaker but it's not
quite as good as I thought it would be
and it's you know it's still quite loud
it's decent better than average it's
just a little awkward only having a
sound come from half of the phone but
also looking at the front you can't
actually see these with your eyes but
the camera picks it up anyway it's the
array of infrared sensors across the
front of the phone and it's packing a
bunch of these you can see them blinking
in each corner and basically these are
sensors that are talking with a chip in
the phone to be able to tell when you
wave your hand over the phone so it can
show you your notification glance that's
actually it that's what they're for I
mean it's a seriously dedicated sensor
array and you can even see them better
in the white version of the phone
because there are little holes behind
the plastic at each corner but yeah it's
a software feature that Motorola felt
was important enough
to spend a little extra on but speaking
of the software the story here is also
familiar to the last Moto X in the best
possible way
last year Motorola tried really hard to
keep Android as close to stock as they
could and they did did you know they
didn't add any unnecessary crap they
avoided the bloatware they moved to
updating as fast as they can a lot of
stuff they move to the Play Store and
this phone continues that trend and I
love it so so many companies are trying
to add value to their phones via
software which I get
but the adjustments they make are
sometimes just change for the sake of
change or some crazy features that
people will never use Motorola has done
basically none of these few adjustments
that they have made have also been
really helpful one of them is now the
ability to name your phone anything so
you had to say ok Google now before that
doesn't wake up my phone because I've
actually told it to respond to ok Jarvis
and I think that's a neat little touch
another adjustment versus last year is
in the peak notifications so instead of
only being able to see one at a time you
can now scroll sideways and peek between
more than one notification that by
itself is awesome and Motorola has
rebranded and simplified a lot of their
other commands so that moto assist and
moto actions and moto display all kind
of work in the background for you so for
example little reader text I live when
you're in a moving car instead of you
know some of the crazy outlandish
features other guys are doing and
another benefit of being so close to
stock Android is the performance is damn
impressive it might not be the highest
end processor in the world it's a
Snapdragon 801 it might not be the most
ram in the world it's you know two gigs
and it might not be the best graphics
chip in the world but the performance of
this phone is right up there with the
best in the world of all the Android
phones I've used and I've used a lot
smoothness and the graphics and fluidity
of the Moto X is right up there in like
the top three with the Google Play
edition One m8 and the oneplus one and
even beating out Nexus 5 I mean this
thing is really smooth so if you
couldn't already tell I'm a huge fan of
the software experience on the new Moto
X and I'm pumped to see how it will do
running Android L hopefully really soon
the other only problems you have and
they're not even really problems they're
more like
trade-offs are the battery life and the
camera and I say these are trade-offs
only because even though this is
technically Motorola's highest end phone
and their flagship showcasing the best
they have to offer it's still only a $99
phone on contract and $4.99 off
contracts so again it's technically
speaking not super high-end and the
first place it shows is the battery it's
meh you know it's only a slight slight
bump from last year it's a 2300 million
power battery now but like the screen is
so much bigger and higher resolution now
that you would think they'd bump the
battery more and I feel like with a
phone this thick they'd have room for it
but nope just 2300 so I'm getting two
and a half hours of screen on time with
my normal use where I typically get
three to four on other high-end
flagships and it's a sealed in battery
so you can't replace it so again it's
it's not really a problem it's not like
it's dying before the end of the day or
anything but it's a trade-off to the
point where I start to alter my use
towards the end of the day to make sure
I don't run out and also I mentioned the
camera so it has that nifty little twist
to open gesture that I use all the time
I love that and similar to last time
some very very simple software just tap
the viewfinder to take a picture you
know the menus are super simple you can
swipe them in and out really easy to get
to the viewfinder takes up pretty much
the whole screen but the optics are a
little bit interesting
so it's a new 13 megapixel sensor that
seems like a good number and it has this
ring flash around the glass now which is
supposed to be in theory I guess a
bigger flash spread but it's too small
to actually matter it's really just two
LEDs inside a ring shape reflector but
when it comes to photo quality the
number doesn't really mean much this
phone is super hit or miss I've been
taking photos for weeks now with this
guy and a lot of times the pictures are
really not bad you know and bright
outdoors and even normal indoor light
this camera can handle anything well it
looks a lot of times like a photo that
came from an LG g3 or another high-end
phone but most of the misses and it does
miss quite a lot are coming from when
you try to take a picture with like a
foreground subject and you tap the
screen to focus but then it just takes
the picture instead of refocusing and
another miss is low-light basically
anytime you think you might need a flash
forget about it it's not good in low
wait it just isn't taking good images I
found I've tried many different ways
that won't do it but the 4k video on the
other hand is actually pretty good I was
comparing it side-by-side with another
phone that shoots 4k video and they
looked about the same so that was
encouraging but one thing about 4k
though is if I switch to 4k in the
camera to shoot and then close the
camera app and then open the camera
right back up again it's back to 1080p I
actually want to be able to keep 4k on
all the time but I can't either way the
camera is just not a high point on this
phone it's definitely not going you know
overall to take quite as good images in
the same range of conditions as other
high-end smartphones and like I said the
battery isn't quite as good either so
they're trade-offs because as Motorola's
high-end phone this moto X is going to
be compared to other companies highest
end phones and those are the areas where
it falls short but really when it comes
down to it I just really like using this
phone I love that they didn't try to do
too much with the software they're
sticking to their guns of that pure
Android experience and I think that will
help them get updates faster that'll
help you know not have so much
unnecessary confusing crap
and that's great and so that plus a
similar design to last year and curves
that match last year's phone this is a
very comfortable step forward doesn't
really stick out too much not too flashy
it just it gets the job done it's a
great phone solid flagship for Moto just
don't forget the price when you go
comparing it to the other guys so that's
my Moto X 2014 review it's still an
awesome phone and I was still recommend
it for anyone who likes what they see in
review videos like this but good luck
finding it and I hope you get your hands
on it if you really want it so either
way that's minute thanks for watching
and if you enjoy this video feel free to
give a thumbs up down below it would
help and also there's a subscribe button
below for if you want to see more videos
like this as soon as they come out thank
you for watching I'll talk to you in the
next one peace